welcome back y'all during the holidays
we had Danny Dorito here promoting his
animated movie migration I love him so
much and if you have a teen yet it's a
great watch for the whole family it's so
good the thing is those was that Danny
and I had a lot to talk about we're both
talkers so much there was an overflow of
great content you're welcome America in
advance luckily we have a chance to
share it right now with you here is our
Kelly extra with Danny DeVito starting
with maybe the craziest audition story
I've ever heard um so I heard also
whenever you used to audition that used
to do crazy things at your auditions
well like what does that mean well the
thing about an audition is you want to
make an impression so yeah you want to
really stand out and a couple of them I
one was my first one was I was
auditioning for a play that was at the
public theater and I you know no you
know you just go to all these auditions
when you're an actor everybody who who
tries to do this knows the drill and you
go and you wind up meeting the casting
directors and they know you after a
while if they bring you in for many
things and some a lot most of them you
don't get you don't get so but you want
to make an impression and there was this
one director who was doing a a play was
doing three peny Opera okay and it's and
I said look it's a small part it's one
monologue it's like like you know open
the door when you open the door because
I knew the casting woman I said stand
back just stand back and she said oh
Danny you know like what are you gonna I
said don't worry about it doesn't you
know
so she did it and I laid down and I
rolled
in right and I was doing my monog I
rolled while you're rolling yeah I
started it by the time I got to the
middle of the audition it was a little
speech I was actually on my back looking
up at the
director and he's looking down at me
like this guy
is yeah no not funny I was going to say
with an F is insane and and and uh you
know and I finished and I just kind of
and everybody was like you could hear a
pin drop and a guy went like this thank
you very
much I didn't get the point you waited
by the phone
wait you I hear you also have a unique
warm-up that you do like in theater like
I have a
trampoline like the mini trampoline like
about this size no I have right little
bit lower than this and I put it in my
in in my dressing room and before you go
you know the the whole idea is you got
to get you Juiced up you saw the show
pretty high energy and and so uh I need
that you know I need to get in there and
yeah so anyway I get in there before you
know I come early get get ready I get
disheveled my hair is way way wilder
than this in the show yeah and
uh testify to that and uh you know and I
get ready to go no because we we go
right from the jump as soon as that
curtain opens uh uh you know the
audience is ready in for a ride you got
to hang on so we go and so I need to get
my stuff going you know my blood and all
my lymph glands everything you need to
get pump this is your pump so I pump on
this thing I go up and down yeah I get
ready on that yeah I cannot skip or jump
on a trampoline without smiling well
it's a great thing I know it makes me
happy the thing I have to do though is I
really do have to hold
on oh I have to hold on I'll hold on to
the wall or I'll hold on to like there's
like a a coat hook that's nearby that
that I I dread winding up on you know
but but I I hold on to
it I I'm the I'm like not I'm a bad mom
I will get on with my daughter and be
like let's play crack the egg and I'm
trying to pop her up she's like Mom
don't jump with me don't jump I'm like
I'm trying to just make her fly like
yeah I'm opposite um I've also been
highly injured on one before I like
right before you can edit this out but
right before it was school picture day
the next day this is literally what
happened I was on my friend Lauren's
trampoline and I I was trying to see how
high I could get and I was like all a
sudden I was up there I was like oh my
God I was tall as this tree and I was
coming down I was like what I am not
over the
trampoline and I racked myself and then
fell on the ground and face hit a fire
ant pile have you ever had fire ant
bites well it looks like acne and it
literally was like I had fire bites that
look like
pimples I was really cool in
school I was I was hit on an
extraordinary amount of
times all right y'all going to couch Dan
migration you won't regret
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home